and i think that uh when i'm looking um
on candidates especially um in in
leadership roles and people that i would
like
uh to to build the culture um of our
company
at the end of day and i think that the
most critical thing is
the passion
and the eagerness to succeed
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders meet ken admati platform general
manager and vice president of product
explorium explorium provides an external
data platform that automatically
discovers relevant data signals to
improve advanced analytics and
accelerate business outcomes
prior to joining explorium fenn was a
staff member at intel's ai internal unit
and the founder of intel pharma
analytics platform ken holds a bsc in
information systems engineering from ben
gurion university and she was honorably
listed in 40 under 40 by globes magazine
in 2018.
welcome to 20 minute leaders vice
president of product at explorium how
are you
i'm good thank you
happy to be here today thank you
thank you so much for joining me so much
i want to learn from you and i want to
pick your brain and insights on uh you
are you know one of the leaders of one
of the you know fastest growing and most
amazing companies out of the israel
ecosystem and that that is dealing with
a lot with a lot of data questions and
we're gonna
we're gonna dive deep in into some case
studies soon and but other than that
your experience throughout your journey
having also been working at intel and
having been in the ai space and the
engineering space for quite some time in
managerial roles i think you know
there's there's a lot to learn from that
from from an engineering perspective and
from you know the people that you manage
it and what you've observed works and
what doesn't work for people to to
continuously improve and succeed in
their positions and so again before we
get to that let's start with explorium
and tell me a little bit about yourself
and and what is it about exploring that
drew your attention because you know in
your position you could really be doing
anything you want
thank you so
um i actually started 15 years ago and
my entire career is in the data and ai
space i think that it's a fascinating
domain i love it very much
um i did um different uh product
management roles uh in leadership oil as
you mentioned
um through the years uh i manage teams
and build product at the end of day and
solutions all of them what they have in
common they are in the data space and in
the last uh ten years or so um
specifically um focusing on product that
uh ai machine learning is a big big
component of it uh first of all
understanding how to develop algorithms
that actually uh addressing business
problems uh that can translate into to
our millions and hundreds of millions of
dollars uh each year
and in the last year um with a great
passion uh to the domain uh and
understanding the value proposition uh
that explorer is offering to the world
with like you said an opportunity to
disrupt
uh the industry and to bring uh this
innovative uh platform to the market i
was
i was charmed and
fascinated to come and lead
the product for this amazing company so
here i am
now what does it actually mean to be
running product with your experience and
ai in an ai driven company
how much of the role is is in the
you know algorithmic side of things
versus in the business logic side of
things so it really depends uh when i
worked for intel uh the key challenge
was first of all
to solve
from algorithmic spending being able to
find the best machine learning algorithm
that can demonstrate uh the
um diy for the problem that we are
trying to solve so um needing to have an
algorithm that is better than the
current baseline and being able to
demonstrate that by evaluating and
demonstrating the value in production um
once you have that then you can build
and you need to build an ai platform
that can make sure that that algorithm
will remain accurate over time um being
retrained um
as as needed and all of the surrounding
processes in order to um to actually um
realize the value from the the model or
the machine learning models that you
have in place so that was very relevant
to to the period that i was at intel
but i think today in explorium um what
we are at the end of day delivering to
our customers is an external data
platform our offering enables our
customers to enrich their internal data
together with external data this is what
we bring
i'm a very
developed very rich and start of
data catalog that either we are
producing ourselves or we are acquiring
that data and the actual platform itself
a do the matching which is a very
complex problem being able to understand
that company a uh that
that appears in the customer database is
actually
the same company that we have in
multiple different data sets and that we
are requiring so it's a very complex
problem so first of all we are enabling
the matching but not only that we are
enabling to understand what are the
really data
sets features signals that are actually
relevant
to the problem that our customers are
trying to solve so let's use an example
let's say that we have a fintech company
that would like um to score um
their um their applicants for a certain
um loan uh or insurance company that
would like to determine what is the
premium that a certain candidate company
would uh actually are going to pay based
on the risk level of that company so in
order to determine that they need to do
some kind of uh due diligence um on the
company on the user they need to
understand that this is an actual user
uh this is a legitimate um request and
all information that can help them to
understand whether that applicant will
default their loan um uh when time times
so they want to minimize the risk for
their business so they uh they're coming
to uh to explore them and uh based on
the very minimal information that they
have on uh the applicant that submitted
a certain form they're getting a very
rich set of information
some demographics and it could be
if it's a company what is uh their
financials and what is their um
latest uh web activities and if it's a
physical store um what kind of audience
is included
near those stores
or what is the food traffic around that
store so we have a very rich
set of data that can help actually help
those customers to get a better
understanding um on whether at the end
of day they need to approve or
or deny
those requests
and we are enabling to access that data
in a very easy way and also not just
connecting to all of our data but to
actually to select what are the most
relevant and important uh
elements of that data that actually uh
impacts their bottom line
right now as vp product
how do you balance customization or
personalization for for the for such you
know case for for such specific cases
versus
an overall challenge of developing and
generalized technology that could be
suited uh specifically you know with
without too much hassle
so we are uh we are building a
horizontal platform so it's always um
there is always a tension between um
understanding um
a use case by by a customer
and uh especially when the company is
yelling the startup lab
has some limited number of customers um
going and build something for that
particular
use use case or customer
the challenge and i think that great uh
product organization is uh try to
understand okay
this is the specific use case what are
the capabilities and how we can
generalize them so it will be relevant
to multiple use cases and it's hard at
the beginning uh when you have one use
one customer or
very few use cases uh
um so obviously you are building
something that is more closely to what
you see but as time goes by uh the
ability to generalize and to build
components that can be re um reused in
multiple segments in multiple use cases
this is what some what turn us uh at the
end of day to be on a horizontal
platform that can suit and and fulfill
many use cases in in different
industries and and
with different customers with that said
obviously
um there could be cases where you will
package your horizontal platform and
decide that you want to focus in a
certain vertical and these are the the
components or the building blocks that
are relevant uh to that vertical and you
will package it because you want to
address
additional personas or
user perhaps that are less tech savvy
but um all of those solutions at the end
of the day are relying on the same
horizontal uh platform with the same
capabilities and i think that this is uh
when i'm managing a product organization
this is my expectations from my product
managers is to hear what is the business
use case and knows to translate that
into a reusable technology that can
serve and we can later on market it
with
other industries and other verticals as
well
very very cool very very cool and i want
to transition to
your experience now as a manager and you
know as you're building these
complicated platforms you're working
with with a lot of different personas a
lot of different engineers you've
observed what works and what doesn't
work and what helps people move forward
tell me a little bit about your you know
you both your own managerial style but
also what you've observed about the
growth of others and what helps them
grow or or hinders their growth
so like any other companies we are you
know uh in in the tech industry
for sure with uh with the promise we we
are hiring
very very intensively and i think that
uh when i'm looking um
on candidates especially um in in
leadership wars and people that i would
like
uh to to build the culture um of our
company
at the end of day and i think that and
the most critical thing is
the passion
and the eagerness uh to succeed uh it
was funny um
last saturday um i was listening to the
interview of abhishek
that just won
uh the olympic medal and she was she's
young and she was talking immediately
after um she won the medal and it was so
authentic and she said something that
resonates very very well with me she
said um she was asked um 20 seconds
before uh the end of the fight and she
was losing and someone was asking her
how did you turn uh
um
the the score upside down and she said
i just wanted it more and and i think
that uh that says um all of it i think
that uh if you are
you have the passion you are
you want to succeed you never give up um
you learn all the time and you're
curious
in my mind obviously you need talent um
you need to have a certain skills uh
but
that's
it's not enough uh i saw many many
talented people that were you know
uh they did the work and and you know
and and and their
a curve of uh promotion or you know the
the things that they owned at the end of
the day
um were not uh that great but i saw
people that perhaps started in
much lower uh from a lower place from uh
skills or talent perspective but they
were
so eager
to win
to you know never give up again and
there was
learning all the time and from my
perspective you know that's uh
makes all of the difference so when i'm
hiring and when i'm building teams i
think that this is
the number one uh treat that i'm looking
for
and and obviously um creating a diverse
and uh
and and you know you need the balance
not all the people can be uh those kinds
of players but i think that at least for
the people that you're putting in
leadership or
others
it's making all the difference
now when you're looking specifically at
engineers and obviously in engineering
is not the same as a taekwondo in terms
of in terms of energy levels and in
terms of you know outward excitement
how do you then navigate that passion
either as a hiring manager
or
or simply as somebody who's examining
the people that are that you're working
with and deciding who who
who who's the right fit to to to
continue up up the ladder how do you
navigate through you know the lack of
outward expression of excitement that
you may see in in other industries
i think that you see that very clearly
you see that how much they are
interested and to understand the
business aspect or the actual product
and not you know just focusing on
uh their you know specific tasks how
creative they are perhaps you know to
to
initiate new ideas
um how um they are addressing things
that uh they don't know or new
challenges i think it's very um very
clear you you can see it
very fast
and you want to be um
these are the exact people that you want
to promote uh at the end of day because
this is the spirit
uh that uh they will pass along
and i think that
um in general i i strongly believe that
engineers um once they understand uh the
business or where the company would like
to go and connect very strong to the
product
uh it makes their ability to deliver
um
their features in a much higher quality
and so i i think that it's very
obvious um and you see that very fast
um who are the ones that just give me my
task i want to code at that set versus
people that
look um very broadly they ask questions
um and of course
they deliver the highest quality
uh drive things forward obviously
um so and this is uh what differentiate
uh i believe the ones that are
um you know succeeding at the end of the
day
so to close to close the loop on on this
passion and excitement where do you lie
on the spectrum are you more excited
about
the
the engineering side of things the
problem-solving side of things are you
more interested about the business logic
and and how technology is disrupting
that the the intersection of the two
where do you lie
i i'm as a person i never like to choose
i i
will always say is i i like both and and
and i think that this is also um um very
um existing in my career um
in at the end of that my passion and the
things that i love is
product management i love to
understand how i can translate business
problem
into um a working product
with that said um
what i did i think in in the last eight
to nine years i led um um
atrogenius uh teams composed from a
product engineering uh data science team
uh because i love to um to have an
end-to-end uh ownership the ability not
just to define on what we work but to
actually
build
an execution machine that knows to
deliver um
those requirements or those features
so
um
at the end of the day my passion after
your question is
is product management and and business
but at the end at the same time leading
an organization that can actually make
that a reality
is uh the sweet spot uh from for my
career at least
very very cool now hannah i want you to
take me back a little bit and share with
me what you know even before you know we
got into engineering and ai what really
fascinated you as a kid what what really
sparked your curiosity
um
i think that um
it's hard for me to say i think i i i
didn't think that i will end up being
engineer i i i was always very strong um
you know um as a student uh i i learned
computer science while i was school so i
really like
at the end of day being able to solve
problems
and to get an instant feedback on what
you do so i'm i'm very uh i have a very
analytical uh type of uh thinking i like
challenges uh
and so i think that this is what uh
characterized me as a kid i was actually
sure that i will be a doctor uh and i
have that dream uh for several alleles
uh
and then um
going outside of uh the army i decided
that i actually
like uh
the analytic um challenges and this is
what i wanted to do
um so this is why i decided to
go and and be an information system
engineer and you know life uh i was
lucky in some
it's always helped and i always
navigated into ai and
uh and in data
and
so i'm very fortunate uh but i don't
think that you know it was something
that i
since i was 12
i i had this is what i had as an
envision it's not the case
no what what inspires you today in your
day-to-day
i think that uh we're today
working for explorium
what's inspired me is the size of the
opportunity i think that being
part of something that potentially can
be big
the fact that we have so many
opportunities um
as i said uh i like to do a lot of
things
and
the fact that i have today a playground
where we have so much to do and so many
opportunities and
uh i'm sure that um in the next few
years we will create
um a lot of different product lines
under uh the explorium external data
platform umbrella
and and i think that this um is
fascinating as well as building a
company uh that can generate uh that
size of an impact and and be
a part of a leadership team uh that
build a company with
a culture that i believe uh that i would
like to be part of that company um a
very significant company that is based
here in israel
so all of those things together excites
me very much and it was a key part of my
decision joining explorer and and i can
tell you that one year after
it's
it's even exciting it's more exciting
so very very cool i love it and what are
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
wow
that's a
challenging question um
[Music]
i think that um
i'm a very passionate person uh
i think that uh i have a very i'm very
much i have a self
self-motivated person
and
very emotionally attached
to any everything that i do inside and
outside of my work
i'm a very emotionally attached person
um so
these are probably the three words i
would uh select
wonderful
thank you very very much this was a
really really great i i really enjoyed
it and it was fascinating to hear about
your own perspective with your journey
with exploring your your understanding
of the importance for engineers to be in
touch with the business aspect and and
to and to attract motivation and
inspiration from that but at the end
that it's all about wanting to be the
best and wanting to succeed regardless
of the field
thank you for everything and stay safe
and stay healthy
you too thank you so much and
uh
it was a pleasure uh be here and thank
you for the invite thank you